a logical part and polio gets portfolio
this week I will be implementing my new
portfolio page
[Music]
[Music]
I started Session two brackets that's
autocrat fixing and one thing to
remember is that this extension will not
work if I don't change the CSS so I have
to at least at you know free space it
held us when it at the space and move
next place but to read the code in CSS
file in order to get all of these
prefixes probably works and hopefully
right now everything should be fine I
can start working if I think the project
is best to start with goal and the users
because the fighting the users and the
goal has been to a checked revise if I
foods their rights thanks here I want to
show the doer the front-end developer I
want to make it up to date I want to
show the current level of progress I
want to show the current level of
knowledge and I want to show also the
personality that I have this seems to
face the needs of the users that will
come to the stage and also it seems to
fit my goal so let's have a look at the
sketch the surprise the designer was
made few weeks ago it was presented in
one of the blocks before I like coming
back to desires after time and I can
decide right now if the solutions I just
add an still appeal to me right now I
wanted to tell a story
starting from who I am going through
what I do how I do it and allowing the
option to contact me this page will be
focused on being Frank and
on showing the current level of my
knowledge the current level of what I
can do with code and design I wanted to
show my photon development side so I
want to show me and this part of me that
is connected with code and design
[Music]
because of the history of Lexus and the
fact that it wasn't supported fully in
the beginning the majority of the
features previously I bumped into the
article saying now the newsplex box
former for the whole grid system because
it's you know we cannot rely on browser
support yeah and there are other minuses
of doing so and today I was just reading
something completely different and it's
very crucial also to take care of the
date of the articles of the news that
you are reading so these were from this
year from summer let's make the whole
thing in flexbox and Saturn I want just
any ready-made framework
[Music]
it's celebramos dia del programa
daughter see perfect so we are
celebrating that program and day so
[Applause]
someday we'll get to know that it's not
your thumb that are going to learn that
schools not playing
[Music]
I'm just announcing the next coffee and
curved meeting bar become Malaga
[Music]
[Music]
it's a lockout fresh Malaga manga isn't
it a pleasure to live here while
learning you need a lot of vitamins and
minerals in order to properly
using the time by the running or using
the family eating alone it's gonna use
this productive time it was like rain
brag awesome food and right now let's
get back to code it's where they the
middle of the week I just watched a team
hierarchy for design principles from
methods since this year is shot with
Adobe and using experience design as
always with other laws that I read the
examples and I will link and below in
this video description because it's
something that you shoot for sure to
watch it's worth in the evening I just
finished working on the responsive now
that's it for today let's go to the day
in the needles and Quivers Thomas in
Malaga agonal hablar en español porque
all st. Lisa whoever posted español para
entender toda la gente que Devaki
necessitous hablar en Espana casino and
no es facil para vivir rocky cuando JSI
hablando con la gente Terry
and en de mayoría porque estas palabras
e yes mas facil para key and Andalou
assume poquito mas TV silver gasps black
Santa every I'm going for the bus today
is the new
the sign for the store it would be
pretty impassive because it would be
five times a week and if they are half
two hours it took me quite a lot to get
here so I will need the thing about the
car because we haven't needed it yet we
haven't needed it before but here going
each day to this Spanish course it will
be pretty time-consuming my superpowers
speaking polish but the english or
spanish are my second languages
because I done those better so well I
want to learn and more to understand
that just so many people here around but
also people that work or during the tech
meetups because very often people here
in Spain do not want to speak English
when you work in a huge corporation it's
not a problem because usually people are
all around the world and in Malaga is
very international but local people and
you know people from tech in local tech
meetups they were often speak just on in
Spanish so I want to understand them
more learning foreign languages
especially those like you know Chinese
English or Spanish it's very helpful
communication is the key
[Music]
I'm waiting at another bathtub and I got
another seven minutes away I can use
this time for a new podcast and things
like that but it doesn't change the fact
that there is a lot of time traveling
[Music]
it's Friday
[Music]
during the implementation of flexbox
bread I noticed that they shared the
similar traits that is that's why I
divided them into the sections this is
the first one about section these two
will be in number two so they they are
about portfolio medium YouTube and
Twitter will be another so they are more
about social stuff and contact option at
the end will be a kind of footer it's
almost 5:00 p.m. and this is how the
project looks right now it's totally
both reflects got some sass it needs
much more work but let's have a look how
it looks so this is the view on desktop
it's totally Boutros black spots and the
grid is also built with flexbox in order
to start styling it I used fast I'm
building the whole project in brackets
so perfect sayings and combining sauce
is done in brackets later I will just on
you upload there are ready CSS to the
introduction server it's fully
responsive
from mobile navigation is not connected
with the JavaScript to be hidden right
now but when it's hidden it will look
like that and right now I got a lot of
boxes a lot of backgrounds but these
colors like for example to spray is just
going to show me to help me build
appropriate appropriate flexbox styles
it lacks footer here so welcome to turn
next week but it will be pretty simple
very helpful this week was the death
tips tutorials Thank You Travis
everything here needs much more styling
it's just what I've managed to do this
week this probably will be a kind of
family leading two to one choose an
article to see you two already
waxey I need to start the section a bit
more - and here I will embed the tweets
right now there are a lot of boxes a lot
of extra backgrounds that will be
replaced soon I'm pretty happy with the
final result from this week because it
gives me the responsive grid system that
I will work on the next week one more
thing about the photo and so if you are
working on your portfolio about page
I'd suggest visiting signs such as photo
feather it's useful when you don't know
which photo to choose as test shows this
photo seems to be one of the best ones
when it comes to business category
that's why I chose it also in my
portfolio about page it's Friday in the
evening time for the week summary
majority of this week I've been working
on the design and
datian of the new portfolio page i was
implementing my own flexbox thread for
the first time that's up series on code
and design my personal portfolio in
twelve hours turned out to be really
great tutorial for this week fortunately
this week I didn't have any big problem
there was one thing with pitching that
was a bit problematic and this was
nothing in flexbox next week I will be
polishing at the side that I started it
will need a lot of work on installing or
copy and testing everything keep on
doing practice with people who know more
and see you next week
[Music]